now first we have big breaking news
tonight from John Solomon now moments
ago he obtained this email take a look
at this right here dated October the
19th 2020 between former acting director
of the CIA Mike Morrell and former CIA
director John Brennan the topic of the
email is soon to be published now
Infamous open letter from 51 Intel
officials discrediting the very true
Hunter Biden laptop Story Only weeks
before the election 9 30 a.m Morrell
asking Brennan quote can I add your name
to the list trying to give the campaign
meaning Joe's campaign particularly
during the debate on Thursday a talking
point to push back on Trump on this
issue Brennan responds 17 minutes later
uh quote okay Michael add my name to the
list good initiative uh thanks for
asking me to sign on now did Brennan
attempt in any way to verify verify the
claims that are in the letter he didn't
ask a single question he didn't want to
corroborate any details and apparently
neither Brennan nor Morrell cared if the
letter was accurate and true they only
wanted to give Joe Biden a talking point
uh in the lead-up to a debate with
Donald Trump and shield Joe Biden during
that upcoming debate and that's exactly
what happened take a look at this
is true about Russia Ukraine China other
countries Iraq if this is true then he's
a corrupt politician right so don't give
me the stuff about how you're this
innocent baby Joe they're calling you a
corrupt politician nobody I want to stay
on the issue of race we're talking about
leadership from Hell president Trump
nobody talking about race right now and
I do want to stay on the issue of race
president Trump you've just respond to
that please because look very quick
there are 50 former National
Intelligence folks who said that what
this he's accusing me of is a Russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the Care four five former heads of the
CIA both parties say what he's saying is
a bunch of garbage
now that was election disinformation but
it wasn't from Russia it was from Joe
Biden the Biden campaign and former U.S
security and Intel officials that went
along this was Their in-kind donation to
help Joe hurt Donald Trump in the
process and lie to you the American
people in the lead-up to an election
nobody checked out that laptop now wait
a second here don't those people care so
much about free and fair elections don't
we get that lecture a lot uh that's what
they say on fake news CNN right they
claim they claim to be so worried about
disinformation misinformation remember
in the lead up to the 2020 election
these people including current and
former government uh bureaucrats and
officials they worked on behalf of the
Biden campaign to willfully spread
disinformation about Hunter Biden's
laptop to you the American people you
had the media mob big Tech the FBI all
these 51 one people all in an effort to
shape the election and make no mistake
they don't regret it one bit hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else